everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today let's look at
maximum product subarray and this is
actually a
dynamic programming problem and i'm
going to show you how to
solve this problem easily so we're given
an integer array of numbers
and we want to find the contiguous
subarray
that contains at least num one number
and
has the largest product so in this case
we have a 2 a 3 a negative 2 and a 4
and the largest continuous product we
can make is 2 and 3 because
2 times 3 is 6. that
is the largest product we can't really
make it bigger because there's a
negative 2 if we multiply this by
negative 2 it's going to be
negative 12 that's not bigger than
6. so what's like your first idea how to
solve this problem maybe
brute force right is there a brute force
solution to this
well we want to find a subarray right so
why don't we just try
every single subarray so let's say all
sub arrays starting at two we got one
sub array
two sub arrays three four right
and for each of these let's just
calculate the product right like the
first one is two the next one is two
times three
the next one is two times three times
negative two
the last one is two times three times
times four and we end up saying that so
far the biggest
is this but we're technically not done
yet all of these sub-arrays contain
two so now let's look at all sub-arrays
containing three so we got
one right just three then we got three
times negative two then we got three
times negative two
times 4 and basically we repeat this
process
now you can tell that this is not super
efficient
the time complexity is big o n
squared for each of these numbers we're
going to end up having
n sub arrays and we see that the total
number of elements we have is also
n right it's n elements in the array so
we're going to get
n times n is n squared so my question is
can we do better and how can we do
better maybe there's some
patterns to this problem that we can use
to our advantage to find a better
solution than
n squared so let's look at one example
do you notice anything about this
subarray well
all elements are positive so what does
that end up
doing like this is all positive so we
got a one
okay and next we want to check this sub
array okay multiply it by two
we want to go even farther check the
three
okay multiply it by three and what if we
kept having positive elements four
five multiply by four multiply by five
do you notice something up until this
point our product is going to be a one
up until this point it's going to be a
two up until this point it's going to be
a six
up until this point it's going to be a
24 up until this point is going to be
120.
if we have positive numbers no matter
what
happens they're going to keep increasing
right
so this is the simple case if we get all
positive numbers
then our product is always going to be
increasing
so now let's actually look at the
opposite scenario what if we had
all negative numbers because all
positives is easy you just multiply
all of them and you get the max product
but with negative numbers it's a lot
more tricky
so let's look at the first number so up
until here the max product is just
negative one and then we we add
a second element a negative two and then
what do we get we get
negative one times negative two and
we know that the product of that is
two right positive two now the last sub
array we check
from all the way from negative one to
negative
three so we introduce one more value a
three and now if we multiply all three
of these
numbers together we see that our product
actually got
smaller now it's negative six and what's
going to happen
if we had a another element over here
what if we had a negative four
then we multiply by negative 4
and now we see that our product is going
to be
24. so you see that when you have
negatives consecutively the sign is
alternating so when you want the maximum
it makes it kind of tricky to have
negatives but we also see that
even though we got a negative six over
here
there's actually a subarray that has a
better solution if you just take
these two numbers negative two times
negative three we get a
positive six so why did we get a
negative six over here
how can we find the real maximum which
is
positive six so even though we're
looking for the max
product sub array we're actually also
going to need to keep track of the
minimum as well and i'm going to show
you why
so first do you at least agree with me
that
if we want to find the max product array
sub array of this of the of the entire
thing
it might be helpful for us to at least
solve the sub
problem which is the max product
subarray of just the first two elements
first and then use that to get
the entire one okay that makes sense
we know that the max product subarray of
this
is two now if we had a positive three
over here
then we would say okay if i can get the
max sub array of the first two elements
and multiply it by
three i'm gonna get two times three it
works when these are positive numbers
but we actually have a negative 3 over
here
so i'm gonna say get the max product sub
array which is positive 2
but let's also get the the minimum
product sub array of these two as well
and what do we know about the minimum
what's the
minimum product sub array of these two
it's going to be
negative two so i'm going to keep track
of both positive and negative
so we have a positive 2 and a negative
2.
we keep the max and we keep
the minimum so now when we want to
compute the max product subarray
when we include this 3 then
we can compute that we can compute that
using
both of these values so we know that
when we take the maximum 2 we get
negative
3 times 2 which is negative 6
and we know when we take the minimum we
get we get
negative 3 times negative
2 and that gives us a result
of positive six so we know the maximum
is positive six and the minimum is
negative six so we take positive six
and put it over here and we can take
negative six
and put it over here and hypothetically
maybe we get another element
and this time and this time whether it's
positive
or negative right so in this case let's
say it's negative 4
we will be able to find the solution
because the
minimum or rather we're looking for the
max product sub array
and we know if we take negative four
multiply it by
the current minimum which is a negative
number
negative six we will end up getting 24
which is what we're looking for but if
you reverse it what if we had a
positive 4 here instead well in that
case we can say okay
positive 4 multiplied by our
maximum right our maximum which is
positive 6. so 4 times positive 6
we get 24. we still get it right so this
if we maintain the maximum and the
minimum
we have all the information we need as
we continue to add more
elements to our array so now let's just
look at
one edge case so we're talking about
positive numbers and negative numbers
but we know that one last
edge case exists the dreaded zero value
right so what if we had a zero value and
then maybe some other numbers three
five our zero is gonna kind of
kill us right it's gonna kill our streak
like look what's going to happen
to our min and max if we take 6
multiplied by 0
we get 0 if we take negative 6
multiplied by 0 we get 0 again
right x times 0 equals zero
and then if we try taking this zero and
making it a product of maybe three and
five
it's going to continue being zero right
because any number times
zero is going to be zero so i'm gonna
decide to handle this
in a different way so anytime we get a
zero value
i'm going to reset our max to zero or
rather to one and i'm also going to
reset
our minimum to 1
and the reason i'm gonna do this is
because i don't want to
kill our product right i'm just going to
say that
zeros are ignored we don't really care
about zeros and the reason i'm setting
this to
one is because then when we start
introducing new values like
3 it's just going to be 1 times 3 right
which is
going to end up being 3 so 1 is like a
neutral value for us
so those are the main things we want to
maintain the max
and minimum of our product and we want
to handle the
zero case by resetting everything
to a neutral value like one okay so now
let's code it out
i'm going to say our result is initially
just going to be set to the max value
contained in nums because we at least
have to set it to some value
we can't just initialize it to 0 because
what if we had an array with just one
number and it happened to be negative
one right
in that case this is our max product
which is
even less than zero so zero is not a
good
default case and i'm going to maintain
the current
min and the current max and i'm gonna
initialize these
to one e because we know one is like a
neutral value
and then we're just gonna start
iterating through
every single number in our input array
we know that if we ever get to a zero
we do not want to handle that we don't
want to add that
as a part of our product so we don't
want to mess up our current min and max
by multiplying it by zero
because then it's going to stay zero
forever so instead what we're going to
do
is we're going to reset our min and
our max to one each
and we're just going to continue to the
next iteration of the loop
if this doesn't execute that's when
we're going to actually
do our code and recompute the current
min
and current max so our current max how
are we actually going to compute it well
in python it's really convenient for us
because we can say okay the current max
could potentially be
the the new number that we just found
multiplied by the current max
if the current max happens to be
positive and n is positive
it could also end up being the
the input value n multiplied by the
current
minimum right what if n is negative and
current minimum is negative then
this could end up being a positive
number which could be our current
maximum
the third option is n itself
because what if we had an input such as
negative one
and eight well in that case the current
min and max is going to end up being
negative 1 and either of those numbers
multiplied by
8 which could be our hypothetical n
value
it's going to end up being negative 8 so
8 it's by itself
which is n is the maximum and
the fun thing about python is that look
we just put
three values into our max function some
languages don't allow for this but
there's obviously ways to get around it
and so now that we have our current max
we can
do the exact same thing for our current
min
so min so we can actually take all three
of these values
copy and paste them and then put them in
the min because
we want whatever the min containing n is
and it could be anything it could be
n times current max n times current min
or
n itself so an example would be negative
one
and negative eight if we multiply
these together we get a positive eight
but we don't want that we want
the minimum which could be just negative
eight by itself which would be
this third case but this is where i
always end up with a bug
so do you see how we actually recomputed
the current max but we want to use the
old current max so i'm actually going to
have a temporary variable
up here temp and before we end up
reassigning current max i'm just going
to compute
current max times n and then save it in
temp so then we can use it
down here so we're going to replace this
with temp
so this way we're always keeping track
of what the current max is
and what the current minimum is and so
we can
update our result after each iteration
of the loop
and we want the max product so we can
take the maximum
of result itself because result could
still be the max
current max and current minimum so
that's actually it like we've done it
and we can
now just return what our result and so
this is actually not
that much code and it's not even like
when you
look at it it's hard to recognize that
it's even a dynamic programming problem
because it's not like we're storing an
entire array like dp
and then having an array we're just
maintaining two values
current min and current max and what
they tell us
is for let's say for example
we were at this value n then we're going
to have
the current maximum of this subarray
and the current minimum product of this
subarray
and then when our n gets shifted to the
next value
we're going to have the current maximum
of these three
and the current minimum product of these
three and then by the time
our n value is out of bounds we will
have the current max
and the current minimum of the entire
array computed
so it runs efficiently and that's
because we're
only iterating through the input so
instead of being n squared
the time complexity is just big o of n
the memory complexity is big o of one
because we are not using an array we're
just using
uh single variables i hope this was
helpful
if you enjoyed please like and subscribe
it supports the channel a lot and i'll
hopefully
see you pretty soon